let's bring you some other news now the
speaker of the cyprus parliament
demetrius c lewis has resigned in the
wake of a cash for passport
scandal an al jazeera investigation
found senior politicians who were
willing to sell cypriot passports to
convicted criminals
the scheme was run to attract financial
investments
into the country in exchange for eu
citizenship well the government
has now abolished that program
let's cross live now to nicosia where we
can join david
harrison i beg your pardon david
harrison has filed an update
from the casino we'll listen to it now
yes well there's been another dramatic
development in cyprus
where the speaker of parliament
demetrius sulius has announced his
resignation
now mr sulius had been hanging on for a
couple of days but we've seen protests
outside parliament on two successive
nights and his name was the one they
were calling for
to resign mr sirius did not admit
any wrongdoing he still maintains his
innocence but he was a key figure in al
jazeera's
documentary which revealed him to be
agreeing to help
a chinese criminal obtain an eu passport
the last couple of days have also seen
him being something of an object of
ridicule
with memes showing him holding a now
notorious glass of red wine
and winking at the camera mr solaris
insists that he will be proven innocent
when the attorney general's
investigation is complete but for now
it's another scalp for the people who
say
that this man is corrupt despite his
objections
and that he has to step down